- I love rap music.
It's my favorite music.
And I love rapping.
And that's what we're going to do
to kind of close out the show.
I'm going to ask, did
someone just say, oh no.
And you're like, oh, we really liked him
and then he had to go and ruin it.
No, we're gonna, we're
gonna do a freestyle rap.
That's the rap made up on
the spot based entirely
on suggestions.
And so to do it, I need your suggestions.
I need everyone here to think of a word,
a topic or a phrase
you'd like a rap about.
- (indistinct)
- Can someone translate that please?
(people laughing)
What was it?
- Cardiff Castle.
- Cardiff Castle?
I know where Cardiff is, it in Wales.
Cardiff Castle.
Boris Johnson has been
suggested too many times before,
so yeah, I know.
That's, you don't have to call him BoJo.
He's, he's our fucking leader.
Show some respect.
We're not like, JoBi, you know,
he's called fucking BoJo, whatever.
BoJo and Cardiff Castle.
Let's come over here.
What'd you guys want to wrap about?
- California.
- Escalators.
- Okay. Cool.
Californian and escalators. Great.
Let's come to this wedge over here.
What would you like to wrap about?
- Come.
- Did you say come?
That's, the thing is, it's such a
basic suggestion, but, in, like,
I've done this for, after
19 years of free styling.
I don't think I've ever had it shout out
at a gig before.
Come. Yeah. All right.
Come, BoJo, Cardiff Castle,
California and escalators.
I guess, I guess middle of the
room, you've been neglected.
- Late stage capitalism.
- Okay.
And Elon Musk.
Yeah. I guess that kind
of, that, that ties
into that, doesn't it?
The harbinger of our downfall.
Okay. Okay. Come, BoJo,
Cardiff Castle, Elon Musk,
and late stage capitalism, and
Californian and escalators.
Okay. Maybe. Yeah, maybe we'll do it.
Let's just drop the fucking beat.
Let's, let's, let's lay some tracks down,
and let's have some fun with
whatever this is going to be a rap about.
He's dialed down the bass red.
You're like, mate, it's
too, it's too late for some
kicking in the stomach base.
We need to, yeah, Red Nose
is onions on the keyboards.
(rap beat)
Maybe speed that up a tiny,
a tigy, a tiny bit, right?
Oh, hello.
Oh, he's got, he's got
the steel drums mate.
Again, tropical.
This is going to be nice. Okay, cool.
We're dropping in upon the beat
then it's off we go.
Number 10, the leader of the Britain land.
That's the BoJo Boris Johnson.
A-wronging many kids by
different ladies.
Married Carrie Simmons lately, had a baby.
She'd be pregnant, arriving soon.
Currently, in Glasgow
light this afternoon.
He gave a speech.
He was like, yo, listen, you lot.
He sounds different to that.
He was there, a cop,
the conference at the parties,
26 he's led the climate targets.
We don't want to miss
you need to respect it.
I know it's a hassle.
He's up in Glasgow.
So they ain't got a Welsh castle.
That's a separate part,
a country south and to the East.
If you'd go and visit,
there may be encounter
of a weird beast, a big red dragon
or maybe daffodils.
Cardiff Castle, is it based upon a hill?
Probably.
It's a defensive fortification.
This sound kind of weird
in the Welsh nation.
They're like, oh, hello.
I'm from Cardiff City.
I can't do it long.
Cause my accent shitty.
If you go to Welsh, you better beware,
it starts to stray from Wales to India
as an accent, you know?
So we move from Swansea
and Cardiff over here.
Yeah. We're on the west coast.
Me, I'll be traveling, kind of laid back.
Maybe I'll be smoking
weed or a spare crap.
And I'm reclined right on my back.
I need to get up there,
but my muscles feel slack.
So I think I pause,
and an hour later I'm like,
Shit, yeah. An escalator.
Why don't I use these grab into the rail.
That's really good.
When your muscles fail.
I shall prevail. Everyone adores.
I like to surf there on the shore.
Now, I'm on the third floor.
Fuck, how'd it even work? This is great.
I'm so high. Oh, look at this.
My mate. He's a surfer
dude with the long hair.
Yeah. California. Everybody's aware.
We have fun. We'll do
stuff in the day later.
We like escalators, fuck, elevators.
They're shit.
Who even needs the lift?
Coming over here, yeah.
It's hard to resist.
You'll need to remind me,
'cause I'm stone like the guy.
What was the word from here?
Shout it out, so high.
Yeah, we got it.
Okay. Wait, that'll be later, the fun.
Just hold it in the back
pocket. That'd be the come.
But I'm taking this.
We're going to have fun.
I ask, "yo, Elon Musk, how
did you earn your cash?"
He's like, "well, started
companies like PayPal
and sold it off and cashed in on that one;
it went well, and then invested."
Very clever, he brought
the electric automobile
and aesthetics together in Tesla.
People were buying and
then the boring company
underground drilling
start trying.
And what's next? Space X, maybe to Mars.
And really, it's an indictment
of this society of ours
that we'll fuck up a planet
and move to the universe.
Surely, you should try and
deal with this shit first.
You start fires,
earthquakes like a schism.
It's a symptom of late stage capitalism,
but that's not as much fun.
Who wants to rap about that?
When you could have come.
Come, if you don't know it,
for some reason is just a
slang term for a male's semen.
You put it out there, erect and straight.
Come now, I prefer ejaculate.
It'd be going there
spraying fucking people like
capitalism.
You say come, but I say jism.
(people cheering)